this morning we're hearing from a
california student who got national
attention for her
very emotional reaction when she found
out she got into harvard university
that's how you have to say it
good reason for that because only about
five percent of harvard applicants get
in
lilia luciano sat down with a teenager
and shares the incredible story of hard
work
and perseverance behind her success
hundreds of thousands have watched it
shared it and reposted it
[Music]
but for santa ana high school senior
cielo chegojin her invitation to the ivy
league is not only proof of her
dedication to school
but a testament to her parents sacrifice
i'd come out of
high school and my mom would pick me up
and she'd drive me to the public library
and she'd leave me food and i'd stayed
there until 10 pm when they kicked me
out
last year her dad a father of six who
immigrated from el salvador
three decades ago was detained by
immigration and customs enforcement
and held at the adelanto detention
center about two hours away from his
family
i just take my homework and i do it in
the car and whenever i'd visit my dad
he'd really encouraged me to stay
focused
so especially because it came from him
during that time i took it a lot more
seriously in the six
months her father spent in detention
cielo became an advocate for other
detainees
i translated for their lawyers i wrote
letters to
the the judge that was presiding over
their bond hearing
and i'm so glad that both of them have
been released
fellow santa ana high school alum gloria
montiel was an undocumented student when
she
attended harvard back in 2005 before
earning her phd
she helped cielo navigate the arduous
admission process
paying forward what others had done for
her
harvard's investment in any one student
from this community
will pay back a thousand fold they don't
just
go and then take off they always come
back and do something for the community
cielo plans to become an oncologist my
grandmother
who is from oaxaca passed from colon
cancer and my
grandfather my paternal grandfather
who's currently in el salvador
has carcinoma what do you want people to
know
about your family's story about who your
dad is
honestly i think i just want people to
understand that
not having a certain immigration status
doesn't make a person lesser than
they're still brilliant people they're
still good people she says this
achievement was not just the result of
her own hard work
but that of her family and her community
my parents do everything and i'm so
happy that i was able to do something
that made them really really excited and
just
feel that their work was worth it
because it really is
for cbs this morning luciano los angeles
i love the squeals and congratulations
to cielo i'm very happy that you got
into harvard and all the points that she
made
right on point what a wonderful young
woman her family must be
extraordinarily proud and they should be
they should be i'm glad how they're all
looking at the computer screen and they
get great news like that
i love it that you let us in very nice